[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
the yeah of the grace
[Music]
my
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen
leaders and fighters for freedom and
liberty and the american dream
the best is yet to come
stand back and stand by
let's please continue on person woman
man camera tv all the networks
all the networks person woman
man camera tv
[Music]
a good memory because i'm cognitively
[Music]
therefore
they call them dumps massive dumps
if my grandmother had wheels instead of
legs
oranges oranges she would be a bicycle
god bless the united church thank you
very much
[Music]
very important messages there of course
and we are standing by
for uh joe biden's white house press
secretary jen
saki to give us a press briefing
tomorrow
is the last stream for a while because
we're going to be on a little vacation
but it's also joe biden's first official
press briefing
i believe it's at 2 pm eastern maybe 1
pm eastern i will be here with you
tomorrow for that
and we are very very much looking
forward to it i expect
endless nasty questions today
i expect jen saki to be asked
questions about whether
or how many or the format
of joe biden's press conference tomorrow
so we're standing by for that
about 20 minutes to go until that starts
and we have
so many different things to go over
yesterday i didn't realize it there were
a bunch of people
requesting so-called normal voicemails
i know we voted down the troy york
voicemails
but there were people requesting normal
voicemails um and some people thought
that that would be interesting
sometimes it's interesting how
uninteresting the quote normal
voicemails are so i'll play a couple of
them for you now
before i do that i do want to say thanks
to unicorn britches
as well as anthale hobo
spidey and david chadman
who now has a um an emote
named after him it's the chad man emote
now yesterday i wasn't able to use my
own emotes is it
colon emote
is that it or is it colon david p
11 chad man
let's see here no that didn't work
either how are people doing that
am i not even a high enough level
subscriber to my own channel to use my
own emotes is that maybe going on
colon david p i see a bunch of them
pop up like i just did the bitcoin one
okay colons are only for bt tv
man listen i don't know guys there's a
david chadman emote
i don't know what the hell is going on
all right so anyway
we've got that it has to be capitalized
correctly that's annoying
okay so let's here's just like random
voicemails just to give people a sense
of what the the voicemails are like
hi dave so i just watched one of your
shows
um i watched the show all the time i
love it um
but the video i watched was about
healthcare
now i am totally for
uh you know the uh nationalized
healthcare
um like socialized care but
one thing i have a question about is so
republicans always say oh we're gonna
fight
for you know we don't want so like as
you guys can see we're a minute in with
two minutes to go
that's never getting on the show because
it doesn't get to the point
you know this is why so many of the
voicemails aren't
usable um
let's see here's one about jordan
peterson
hello david my name is uh jeff hearn
i'm calling from eastern canada province
called newfoundland and labrador
and i just watched your clip on jordan
peterson
um addiction and uh
shame go hand in hand and you know i see
jordan peterson
as a man who has suffered from addiction
and
i haven't been addicted to
benzodiazepines but i do
know that treatment centers don't even
accept
people who are addicted to them because
of the serious
and high impact detox that comes from
them
so i'm sure i'm sure that jordan is a
man with shame
and i'm wondering if his rent and
his uh his message about medicine
killing more people than uh
and it saves is uh maybe um a way for
him to compensate for his
uh for his shame and maybe to put a bit
of a blame on the the medical system for
how he ended up where he did
that's interest that's actually an
interesting voicemail that's an
interesting voicemail
let's see uh here's one on trump for
prison
hello david this is gary from long beach
and
calling you again um you made an
interesting point
on your show about uh the fact that
donald trump
is never going to see the inside of the
prison cell
he could very well be indicted on
criminal charges but
he will never see any prison time and
not only do i agree with that statement
it's not something we do in the united
states but i found something else
interesting
how could donald trump possibly
after everything that's transpired get a
fair and impartial jury of his peers
that's a good point trial it seems to me
there would be no way
to pick a jury that isn't predisposed to
think one way or the other how could you
get impartial jurors it just seems
absolutely impossible at this point in
time that's actually that's interesting
too these voicemails really aren't bad
actually we've got some pretty
pretty interesting uh voicemails here
okay so anyway that's a tour through
so-called
normal or good voicemails by popular
demand
yesterday um let's see elite man says
david you call yourself a gardener but
you cannot even eat a banana without
picking off the tip sad yeah the the
you know 99 of a banana is perfect
the strings and the black tip have got
to go
you will not catch me eating the strings
nor the black tip of a banana
baron steuben says any plans to cover
lula's return to brazilian politics
maybe you know those stories just don't
do well most of my audience doesn't
really follow them
so we're sort of trying to stay uh in
our lane i guess
but i guess to some degree we we will oh
some people eat the banana strings
that's interesting
that's interesting i want to say thanks
to uncle damian
as well as stellar noir and matt o'hayo
as well as demixit for people who just
grabbed twitch subs which i
really appreciate i also want to say
thank you
to um pat gaiman
pat gaiman who just grabbed a
subscription at
joinpackman.com new member number nine
today
very much appreciate that and oh look at
this
laurie constantino just grabbed the
subscription at joinpackman.com
and so did sylvia johnson continuing the
trend of
our female viewers seemingly preferring
to get memberships during live streams
male viewers getting memberships in the
dead of night
when i'm sleeping make of that what you
will
the immoral coupon code does expire
friday
it is immoral 21 very very important
um do i have a referral link for
coinbase
you know we actually do davidpakman.com
coinbase i think if you sign up on
coinbase with that referral link
i think we each get 10 bucks maybe it's
just no i think everybody gets 10 bucks
yeah davidpakman.com coinbase very very
exciting stuff
so we've got that um
we did reach an important milestone as
far as vaccinations go
as you will see here we are now
officially
at 2.5 million average doses per day
over the last seven days i say we're
going to three
i believe we are going to three million
doses per day
and that's a really great thing and this
is with yesterday we only had 1.7
i think we're going to blow 2.5 out of
the water very very soon
extremely soon we are going to be
handling that
very properly so that's good news and
tomorrow we'll do like our weekly update
on cases and deaths what's happening is
the deaths are
are basically flat they're almost
starting to tick up a little bit
but the good news is that the deaths
continue to decline
we are now under a thousand deaths a day
average
it's like it feels insane to feel like
anything good is going on when still
975 people a day are dying it's insane
but you know two months ago we were at
3 500 people a day so
i don't know it's sort of like the good
news and the bad news are the same
and that's that 975 people a day are
currently
dying of the virus in the united states
okay
so that's the latest as far as that goes
brown sylvania says krispy kreme is
giving out free donuts to everyone who's
vaccinated for the rest of the year
seems ironic since obesity is high risk
for covid i thought
the exact same thing brown sylvania
anything we can do to get people
vaccinated is good but doing something
that makes them more likely to get
serious covet if they get it
seems less good to me i don't know
i don't know thanks to peter murphy for
signing up at joinedpakman.com peter you
were a great american as sean hannity
would say
and you are new member number 12 today
very much appreciate that i also want to
say thanks to megawatt
for signing up via twitch your new
member number 13.
i have been vaccinated people asking i
am
i got my second dose
wait a second i got my second dose a
month ago
um oh hold on guys i gotta
i've gotta ban someone i apologize
we just dropped the band hammer uh
oh a lot of people getting banned today
that's sad
it always bums me out because i always
i'm like what's going on in people's
lives
that they have to come and do this stuff
to my streams
i feel more bad for them ryan via super
chat
says going on a road trip through new
england this fall passing through boston
what are your favorite restaurants in
boston or in the new england area in
general yeah i have a lot from when i
from when i lived in boston there's so
many
uh it's i you know how do you how do you
even i don't know it depends on the
genre
depends on the genre um thank you to
multibeast for the 13 months subscribed
as well as
miravus pants for subscribing via twitch
numbers 14 and 15.
no i have no unban
oh no i do have some oh hold on a second
i've got my gavel we are going to
adjudicate an unban
request here is a user who participated
as follows
13 days ago this is a user
blazers blazers came into the chat
14 13 days ago and said yo
dave you made a much better youtube
model than a political commentator it
seemed like you were
way more intelligent when you weren't
talking at all
okay next comment i was never a youtube
model or a political commentator and
then
idiot then they were gone for 13 days
they came back today and said
stick to youtube modeling shilling for
senile biden
i guess they mean senile but they don't
even know what they're saying for senile
biden requires far less self-respect
they were banned and their unbanned
request
is ah poor baby got his feelings hurt
boo hoo that is going to be
they seem obsessed with me they will be
denied
and that ban has been made
permanent um
i think do i have one more the weirdest
thing is happening
all the time it says there's one
unbanned request but there's really none
and when there's one it says two i don't
know
it seems to be a glitch
seems to be a glitch but that is the
only unbanned request
that i'm seeing some moderators have
actually told me they they will
sometimes get messages
from some of these people which is
really uh
really not so good let me put it that
way
we do have a few interesting clips to
play for you
fox news has been particularly unhinged
lately
here's a laura ingraham segment from
last night let's make sure we have good
volume here
here we go the democrats prefer
illegal immigrants to anyone who ever
voted for trump
oh okay that's quite quite that's quite
an assertion here's another one
i think that they basically intend to
treat the gop
going forward as a terrorist
organization
hmm what a strange show
what a very weird show here's lindsay on
hannity let's listen to that
troll god bless the custom agents who
are dealing with the biden
administration [ __ ] show
at the border ooh edgy lindsay swearing
on fox wow
i'm going down with 18 senators friday
and if i'm denied the ability to look is
that an accent where you change
all the vowels like instead of senators
it's
sinaters that's just a southern accent
right is that a south carolina thing
i'm not making fun of it i'm genuinely
curious about that like every vowel is
replaced with a different vowel
sin aters again to any place i want to
go
we're going to shut the senate down
where all the liberal hypocrites where's
aoc
where are they where show them to me
here's ted cruz well sean that's exactly
right and and the modern day left is
is more and more extreme they have this
bizarre antipathy
to to god and to prayers so anytime look
look
all of us have had people who've lost
loved ones and then the first thing you
do when someone has lost a loved one is
you reach out and say hey i'm lifting
you up in prayer i'm praying for you
your family
that's not the first thing everybody
does i know you're hurting and and
may god's peace be with you and the left
treats that like how
dare you believe there's an omnipotent
god who could actually love you and care
for you
well then why did all those people die i
mean that's what did they
did they sin or i mean it does raise
real questions
that's not weird to me here's hannity
talking about
blue check mark people tweeting in their
underwear
blue check mark keyboard warriors on
twitter
in their basement and their underwear
almost giddy
so that's fox news yesterday um
sort of disappointing i guess but not
not particularly surprising
um okay let's see
what else we've got here
um
all right so that's that oh p some
people are saying
are there any more um telemarketer prank
calls yet
no there aren't yesterday i previewed
let me see here i previewed
a telemarketer call yesterday for people
some people liked it we can look at
a little bit of it again i've been
asking people if you get
calls from uh telemarketers and they say
call me back
like the hold on a second the irs scam
or you know any of these different scams
send them to me
and i will try calling them back and see
if we can get something interesting out
of it
yesterday's was kind of funny let me see
if i can play it for you here
where was this i think it's here all
right let's take a listen to this this
will be published to youtube
yes yes
i'm going to connect you with our legal
team so a tax specialist can review your
case
here we go oh may have it please yes
it's seven eight four three seven
okay seven okay seven eight four three
seven okay
so sir uh can i have your first and last
name
yes uh first name is diego d-i-e-g-j-o
and last name is sala bumbersmith
i can spell it if you need me to
can you spell it out for me sir yes it's
s z a
l a b u
m b e r
and then smith like you know smith
okay and their phone number let me
verify it's
774. so i'm going to pause that that's
someone else's phone number but just in
case
i gave a number that actually links to
someone's file i don't want to put the
number up
it's not it's not my number like i just
randomly called this
okay so thank you for uh patiently
waiting on the line so according to the
file
it looks like the reason why john called
your earlier because
the ras has made some recent changes to
the first
fresh start program due to brush star on
a virus
so it looks like you are eligible for
some relief i thought it was better 21
not fresh start
on your tax that did you get uh the
information that was sent
in the email or in the mail no i i just
got
a voicemail you're saying that there
were changes made by the ras
yes sir wow and i didn't get anything
about i just got a voicemail from john
uh no problem sir uh because i pull up
the file so i can probably go over the
information with you
so according to the notes on the file it
looks like there were several things
mailed to you
so there are new federal relief programs
for those
experience experiencing hardship due to
due to their tax debt so right now
taxpayers can be eligible
jew yes oh my god they're uh packed that
jesus
[Music]
taxpayers can eligible to receive
forgiveness and
relief on a portion of their tax debt
based on a few factors now please
remember
these are relief programs so not
everyone qualifies
so however if you do qualify uh our
attorney will
able to review your file and possibly
help you with uh
to get the forgiveness or resolve your
tax debt
so let me go over the qualifying
questions with you before i send you to
the legal department okay please yes
okay so is your tax that above or below
ten thousand
ten thousand dollars absolutely
abs approximately uh sir how much do you
owe
um uh eleventeen hundred
eleven hundred eleventeen hundred yeah
okay so are you in bankruptcy right now
no no
okay so uh since these programs may be
based on your income
are you currently employed yes
okay so approximately how much
is your monthly income oh that's
that's tough i mean that's a very
private thing and i know
i don't know if you're based in the is
the ras based in the united states
uh yes sir but uh we are receiving calls
uh offshore oh you are
yes sir we are only working on the aria
uh irs
but we are receiving calls offshore
i'm just trying to are you with the irs
ras or the rs
listen monthly income is tough i mean
what does my monthly income
need to be let's put it that way
because so that uh we can know how uh
how can you pay
your tax debt now hold on a second i
thought this was about
i thought this was tax relief where you
give me money but now you're saying i
have to pay
the ras money no no
no sir we are this is only a qualifying
question
if you qualify are you buying or selling
i guess every question
i am just i am not selling anything here
i am just
qualifying you for the relief program
i'm getting dangerously close to being
qualified here can you guys tell how
close to qualification i am
sure so let's see my monthly income
is about eighty thousand dollars
okay so go ahead and verify
i imagine he's like working three phones
now your first name and last a
name again for me yes first name diego
d-i-e-g-j-o
last name salabumbersmith
that's s-z-a i don't know why i put the
z in there at the beginning it's a
silent z
l-a-m-b-u-m-b-e-r
smith as in smith
okay okay perfect let me go ahead and
get you over to one of our agents at the
firm okay so we're gonna stop it there
the full call will be published to our
youtube channel
uh during the david pakman show break
next week
and um the conclusion to the call and i
have others
i have um
okay nothing starting i have other calls
is the point that i could be making very
soon
i want to say thank you to jared perkins
who just signed up
really strongly at joinedpakman.com
using the coupon code better21 i also
want to say
thanks to jeff dimarco for signing up at
joinpacman.com
with the coupon code immoral 21 an even
crazier coupon code
those are new members number 16 and 17.
i also
can't help but thank sobe for the twitch
sub
rhinodactyl oh just the two of them okay
that's numbers
18 and 19. let's look at some super
chats here because they are coming in
fred ferret says louis de joy has left
the usps in such a mess that they lost
my wedding dress the seller's supposed
to send another one who
knows how long it'll take i only have 93
days sorry to hear that ferret queen
javier says this is great eleventeen
mini says david i'm getting my vaccine
tomorrow i'm kind of nervous because i
have a metaphobia
is is is a metaphobia um
fear of being nauseous
fear of vomiting oh
i'm not hearing of anybody vomiting from
the shot
i don't know about that i would talk to
a doctor
uh asparagus video wants to know what
are my thoughts on asparagus could i get
a sound bite of you saying hello
asparagus video thank you for everything
sir i like asparagus but only when it's
in season you know sometimes i'll see
you know in the northeast you've got uh
you know uh december asparagus
seems a little bit dicey to me i don't
know that i would go with that
that's a that's a red flag to me dark
pepsi says hey david have you read any
articles or watched any clips about the
suez canal traffic jam
caused by a shipping container blocking
the waterway i did i did i don't know
the details of it but i did see that
hi everyone whoa okay here we go
okay as you may know or now you will
know
today is equal payday and we have two
special guests from the council of
economic advisors
chair cecilia rouse and member heather
boucher
sheriff cecilia rouse recently served as
the dean of the princeton school of
public and international affairs
she is a renowned labor economist with
expertise centered in the economics of
education
and equality cecilia previously served
as a member of the council of economic
advisors in the obama biden
administration
and on the national economic council in
the clinton administration
she is the first african-american and
just the fourth woman to lead the cea
in the last 74 years of its existence
heather is a long-time economic
counselor to president biden
and previously served as president and
ceo of the washington center for
equitable growth
and expert on the impact of structural
inequities on economic growth
she served as the chief economist for
secretary of state hillary clinton's
2016 presidential transition team and as
an economist for a range of think tanks
and the congressional joint
economic committee they both have quite
some resumes
i'm going to turn it over to them they
will each make some brief remarks and
we'll be able to take a couple of
questions and they actually have a
meeting
with the vice president they'll have to
get to shortly thereafter so with that i
will turn it over
great start here strong good afternoon
it's actually it's a it's a pleasure to
be here today so today is equal pay day
a day that is a symbolic representation
of how far
into this year women must work work to
catch up to what men made in the
previous year
women working full-time year-round are
typically paid just 82 cents for every
dollar paid to men
it's a reminder of the work they're
getting closer to the real number
they're no longer using 77 we have a
video on the real number
opportunity to reach their full
potential
because of this gender gap women lose
thousands of dollars each year and
hundreds of thousands of dollars over a
lifetime the disparities are greater for
black and hispanic women who earn 63
cents
and 55 cents for every uh dollar that a
white man earns what does this mean
so a black woman must work around 19
months to earn what a white man would
earn in one year
for a hispanic woman that is almost 22
men's
so what does this really mean it means i
shouldn't be standing here today
in front of you and really i should be
here sometime in august
so what are we doing about it president
biden and vice president harris believe
we must begin
by passing the paycheck fairness act
this bill would be an important step
towards ending paid discrimination
through transparency
and accountability for employers they
believe we must provide paid family and
medical leave
make childcare more affordable and build
pipelines for training that enable women
to access higher paying jobs
they were also committed to raising pay
for child care workers
preschool teachers home health aides and
others in the care economy
and taking additional steps to increase
wages for american workers
such as raising the minimum wage and
empowering workers to organize and
collectively bargain
both of which are important to reducing
the wage gap for women
we have made progress my daughter is
here today she's downstairs
and when i was her age the gender wage
gap was about sixty percent
compared to eighty percent eighty two
percent today
that said there is still a lot of work
to do the biden harris administration is
working to make sure our daughters have
the same opportunities that our sons do
and to make sure that every american is
given a fair shot to get ahead in this
country
these aren't simply women's issues they
affect all families
the ability of our economy to recover
and our nation's competitiveness
with that i'll turn it over
thank you thank you cecilia um
so the pandemic and the economic crisis
have undermined the health and
well-being of women and children in the
united states
there are now 4.2 million fewer women
working
than there were in february of 2020 in
large part because of the pandemic
millions more women have had to reduce
their hours often because
taking care of the children is a
responsibility that continues to fall
disproportionately on women
our economic recovery depends on us
addressing the barriers that have
hampered women from fully participating
in the labor force
so here's the good news the american
rescue plan
will change the course of the pandemic
and deliver
immediate relief and support to women
families
and their communities critical to
building a more equitable economy
the plan will increase the child tax
credit from two thousand dollars per
child
to about three thousand dollars per
child and even more for a child
under the age of six this means a
typical family of four
with two young children will receive an
additional three thousand two hundred
dollars in assistance to cover the costs
associated with raising children
this will benefit 66 million
children the plan will also increase the
earned income tax credit for 17
million workers by as much as a thousand
dollars
benefiting many cashiers food preparers
and servers
and home health aides those front line
workers who have helped their
communities get
through this crisis many of whom are
women many of whom are women of color
the plan also expands child care
assistance helping hard
hard hit child care providers who are
disproportionately women of color
cover their costs and it will give
families an additional tax credit
to help them cut their child care costs
families will get back as a refundable
tax credit as much as
half half of their spending on child
care for children
under age 13 so they can receive a total
of up to four thousand dollars for one
child or
up to eight thousand dollars for two or
more children
if we add it all up these are historic
actions that will not only help rescue
our economy
they will help support our country's
women and their families
but we know as cecilia pointed out we
have to do more
to close the wage gap and to take steps
to ensure that all women
especially women of color have their
shot to get ahead
and so with that we will take some
questions okay
okay thanks question for you both this
is on
racial economic gaps during the
campaign president biden talked about
wanting the federal reserve
to close income gaps and he wanted to
measure the progress they make in in
closing those racial economic
gaps would you be willing to say if any
steps have been taken so far
towards requiring that sort of thing is
the white house still interested
in talking to congress about um amending
the fed act
to require some sort of measures sure
i'm happy to take that
so um i can't speak to that exactly at
that
this time what i can say is that we are
this administration across the
administration we are committed to
addressing racial
um the racial wage gaps and and racial
and equity gaps
i can say at the cea for example we are
using data
to understand the impact of all of our
policies when we study what's happening
in the economy
we want to look at how it's not just
affecting the average but expecting
anything other than vague answers like
we're using data
in from folks in these positions is
unrealistic
just yesterday and last week he pointed
to the fact that as the federal reserve
is doing its monetary policy
it is looking not just for the average
unemployment rate to
change he is looking to see that the
economy is doing well
for everybody so um you know we are we
are very aligned
go ahead thanks for doing this josh
spoke with ap
lots of americans thought educational
attainment would close the gender wage
gap
and racial inequality but in fact if you
look at college grads
the gap widens between men and women
some of that is due to age
but what are the factors driving here
why hasn't educational attainment
delivered more
great questions you know educational
entertainment was actually very
instrumental in
making some of the gains between my
daughter before
the wage gap when i was coming up and my
daughter so we know that
women getting higher years of schooling
was very important in the early years
but now we know that women on average
are getting more schooling than them
so that is why it is not contributing as
much and what we see then
is that there are other factors so we
see that the wage gap among
young adults is actually fairly small
and it opens up
particularly when women start families
which is why the care economy
and the efforts we're making to ensure
that workers not just women but all
workers
can balance work and family is going to
be so important
we also know that flexible workplaces is
very important for helping workers to
balance
uh work life you know the work
responsibilities and job
responsibilities
uh claudia goldin at harvard for example
has found that the wage gap is smaller
barbara golden i think pharmacist where
there's just more flexibility
baked into the occupation i don't think
her name's claudia i think it's barbara
i think it really
goes to uh helping women in particular
but all workers balance responsibilities
of family and work
okay um heather you had studied the
statistics on
4.2 million fewer women now in the
workforce than before kobe the president
has said that women dropping out of the
workforce during the pandemic is a
national emergency
are there new measures under discussion
now specifically on that
issue to reintroduce women back into the
workforce part of the
buildback better plan and what can be
done
to bring them back in it's a great
question um
you know i mean the most important thing
that we need to do is wrap our hands
around this pandemic
right so the steps that were taken as a
part of the american rescue plan
to you know deal with the health crisis
make sure that the vaccine gets out all
of those things that is certainly going
to be an important step forward
so that schools can reopen safely and
then of course there are funds
as a part of the american rescue plan
historic investment in
child care centers to help them reopen
safely so
um part of what we see in this decline
in women's employment
is because of their the the fact that
they're responsible for children
um the fact that child care centers have
closed schools aren't open
families are trying to telecommute or
they're trying to go out to their job
and
and cope with children not having
adequate care the right care
that is really um i think going to play
an important role in getting folks
back in to the labor force um
and and i want to stress that's on both
sides right
in those caring economy parts of our
economy these are jobs that are
disproportionately held by women
so um in making sure that schools are
open and child care centers are open
we're helping those women as workers and
also as parents and caregivers so i
think that is those are some of the
first steps that we need to see
um but you know over time making sure
that as you know as cecilia said
making sure that we have that strong
foundation of the care economy
on issues around child care also issues
around
um you know how we help families that
have someone who needs some extra care
or
sort of later in life issues the aging
and the disabled
along with making sure that we have
workplace flexibility and we have paid
leave these are all things that
help make it possible for people who
have care responsibilities to be
full members of our economy and our
society
just very quickly in terms of the
infrastructure package that's coming
next right so that we're talking about
quite a lot of money two to three
trillion dollars what what specific
things do you think essentially have to
be part of that and what role
in all of this does the sort of your
push for the federal minimum wage
increase uh play and how do you how do
you convince
congress that that's an essential part
well i could take a stab at that i mean
yeah um
so you know we
we know that the the president has been
so clear throughout the campaign and
into governing on what his values are
and where he wants to
um guide this economy right that we're
focused on how we can deepen strength
and broaden the middle class that's why
we're so focused on equal pay day
because we know that women
are a key part of you know make up the
workers that make up the middle class
and he's been very clear in his support
of raising the minimum wage to 15
an hour that um these are the kinds of
um focus that we need to have in as the
agenda is built out this is what he's
asked us to focus on
alongside this we need to make sure that
that we are
making sure that the economy is directed
at enhancing supporting
building american competitiveness so
that we're creating those good jobs and
they're available for all people
not just some people but people all
across these united states
yeah i guess what i was just going to
add to that is that right this this next
package is really about investing in our
future
and making the kinds of smart
investments that we know will increase
growth
and we want that growth to be widely
shared so the idea is not just to
increase the size of the pie but to
ensure that everybody gets their slice
unlike many policies that have followed
in the past do you need to i'm sorry do
you need to like
include some kind of private sector
initiatives to
nudge those companies that aren't moving
along as quickly
look i we really can't speak to the
specifics i think you're used to jen
saying she likes to keep her job i kind
of like to keep mine too
um so we are you know we are looking at
the most effective ways in order to make
these kinds of investments that we know
are just so important to our company
thank you so much i think just to follow
up on karen's question
you know making sure that there is
support for the women
is one thing but will there be any
concrete measures
in the buildback that are planned to
make sure the 4.2 million women have
jobs to return to
right that is the exact purpose of the
american rescue plan
right the whole purpose is to get us
through this pandemic
with and to help our businesses that are
viable stay
in business to help the workers who need
help paying their rent um and and
getting food on the table
to stay engaged and not just imagine
that they're going to drop out and drop
out forever we know that the longer
that we have the economic crisis and the
longer that workers are out of the
workforce the harder it is for them to
come back
so that is the entire focus of the
american recipe plan is to get us back
on track
so that by next year we are back to
essentially full of flint
thank you both so much for coming thank
you to have you back for people
interested in the gender pay gap check
out my long form video on that issue
just for you all at the top
as you know this afternoon the president
first lady will be joined
by megan rapneau and margaret purse at
the white house for a virtual event with
other members of the u.s
women's national team where the
president will sign a proclamation
marking equal pay day additionally the
second gentleman is in st
louis missouri for a listening session
on gender equity in the workforce
as cecilia and heather just detailed the
pandemic and economic crisis
have undermined the health and
well-being of women and children the
american rescue plan provides help for
women and families
yeah i agree i think that that earlier
presentation i think we learned
nothing i i i mean they seem like great
people and very qualified but we learn
we learn nothing
to help schools serve all students and
reopen
yesterday on the anniversary of the
affordable care act being signed into
law
the president of course traveled to ohio
um it was a great trip
where he announced that the
administration would expand access to
health care coverage
by extending the special enrollment
period until august 15th i know
a number of you noted that but i just
wanted to reiterate it
since it was late in the day this
morning the president uh was proud to
sign into law the save lives act the
bipartisan
piece of legislation will give the va
the ability to provide vaccines to all
veterans
and boost vaccine efforts for veterans
families and caregivers
it's truly a testament to what
government can do when we work together
he's grateful for the leadership of both
the senate and house veterans affairs
committee
both chairs mark takano and john tester
and ranking members
mike boss and jerry moran as we
announced this morning but to give you a
little bit more detail the president
will travel to pittsburgh pennsylvania
next week on wednesday march 31st where
he will
deliver a speech laying out more details
of his plan to build the economy
back better over the next several days
and this is probably why they were
hesitant to give
more detail he will continue meeting
with his economic team to finalize
details of his proposal
including the scale scope and final
policy components his focus of course
will be on investing in america's
workers
making sure the tax code rewards worth
not wealth delivering on the promises he
made
to the american people when he was
running for president
uh with that go ahead josh thanks jen um
on the shooting in colorado the
president said congress must act
senator senate majority leader schumer
has also said the senate's voiced act
but vice president uh harris said today
on cbs
that she thought the change would have
occurred after the sandy hook shootings
and i'm curious what does the president
think is different this time
and how has he changed his approach so
that this administration
can pass these changes when in the past
it failed
good question well first the president
shares that sentiment as i think many
americans do
that when we saw uh 20 children
murdered when we saw six adults murdered
that that would turn the tide of
congress
we have seen data and statistics still
across the country still broadly support
background checks
i think it's about 80 percent of the
american public support background
checks including
a good percentage of gun owners support
background checks
we've seen states take action since that
time a number of states across the
country have put in
in place a number of laws sometimes
states are the leaders
as we know and we've seen in other areas
of policy making
but i think the president who has been
in public life in public office for
50 years more than 50 years would be the
first to tell you if you were standing
here that
just because you don't get the policy
making the legislation done the first
time
it doesn't mean you quit trying and
certainly uh
tragedies like we saw earlier this week
like we saw last week
mass shootings that are killing innocent
lives leaving family members without
their loved ones is a reminder
of how important and vital that is he
has talked about as he did yesterday
the importance of working with congress
i know the vice president
touched on the fact that if we want
something to be permanent if we want it
to be lasting we need to be legislation
he certainly believes that but there are
also executive actions under
consideration
that we will continue working through
internally and there's lots of leverage
you can take obviously as president vice
president
and then secondly um today's the first
chance for many in the media to see the
situation on the southern border
at government facilities yeah um this is
the first step of transparency what else
can we so expect can evaluate the
situation and present it to the public
well first as you noted um i know all of
you have covered this but just to kind
of reiterate where we are here
so there's a delegation of members of
congress and white house officials
who are traveling to uh the office of
refugee resettlement
at cruiser springs in the influx care
facility there
um there is a network pool camera uh
that will be a part of this journey
which will be uh
which will ensure that there's network
pool coverage or network
pool footage i should say that is
provided to all of the networks so that
you can all see
as the media for yourselves and be able
to provide analysis
on that b-roll footage and we are also
remain committed to transparency and
will continue to work with agencies
on creating avenues for media access to
invisibility into these facilities so i
think our balance is of course privacy
as you all know
it is also that we are in the middle of
a pandemic and that you know these
facilities of course can't become
uh forums for media access all day long
every day
i think we all agree on that balance but
we will continue to look for ways to
increase transparency and
provide additional access go ahead
thank you jen a couple questions on guns
short apa representation
and at what point would president biden
consider taking executive action
instead of waiting for congress to wait
in other words how many
measures would have to fail before he
stepped in
i think he sees it as a vital to take
steps on two tracks because
congressional legislation as the vice
president conveyed this morning
obviously has a more permanent lasting
impact
executive actions are of course an
important lever that every president has
at their
uh disposal there's current discussions
and analysis
internally of what steps can be taken
that that has been ongoing for several
weeks even before these two recent
tragedies uh that um you know he looks
forward to
getting an update on and and seeing what
can be moved forward on that front as
well
so he's not waiting for anything to fail
is is really the answer to your question
what executive actions do you think he's
most likely to take oh she can't preview
anything
it's a great question i have it myself
as well but it's an ongoing policy
process internally
i will say that his view the vice
president's view and our policy team's
view is that
it's not just about addressing gun
access that's important and obviously
there's legislation that's under
consideration on background checks that
they
both strongly support they want to see
move forward
it's also about addressing community
violence and
you know a range of issues uh that our
root causes and and kind of lead to the
the uh the deaths and the uh and the uh
impact that we're seeing that's so
troubling
thank you and then on the other issue um
you know
the white house had conversations with
senators duckworth and hirono
i think one concern that they have
brought is is
the question of who is advising
president biden
from the aapi community
as we see this surge of violence i know
ambassador rice and cedric richmond are
leading
the engagement efforts who
who in the aapi community is having
direct conversations with the president
about
what's unfolding well you mentioned uh
cedric
and susan rice who have been doing
listening sessions for some time and
obviously those will continue to
pick up obviously the vice president who
is the first in the meeting and the last
in a meeting on every issue including
the impact
of the violence and the threats uh and
the uh that we've seen increase over the
past several months against the aapi
community
uh as a member herself of the aapi
community is certainly
uh playing an important role on that and
as we noted in a statement
is aapi asian and pacific islander is
that what it stands for
senior level asian american pacific
islander liaison who will ensure the
community's voice is further represented
and heard not just around crises not
just around an increase in violence but
in american pacific
and uh you know playing an important
role with a seat at the table
and to be clear this is a new position
in addition to the one over
um in public engagement this is the one
that we announced last night so it's
going to be a new
senior level position yes yep will this
person also have a policy portfolio
or will it just be mainly outreach
uh i can get you more specifics i mean i
think that uh when they're all the roles
that are in our liaison playing liaison
roles
uh typically have a seat at the table on
a range of issues so whether it is
healthcare or uh climate or
community violence um so typically uh
it's having a seat at the table in a
range of topics
but i can see if there's more specifics
obviously we have not hired yet because
we just announced this last night
go ahead uh to follow up on region's
question on the president
we were talking yesterday about
executive action on gun reform the
president also was making it clear he
wanted to see congress act yes several
times yes
would he propose his own gun reform plan
that he would present to congress as
we've seen him do
on the coveted relief plan and will we
anticipate coming on the economic plan
would this be something that could
originate
here and not wait for congress to move
you know karen i think it's a great
question there's obviously a lot of
pieces of legislation that have been
proposed
there's these two background check bills
that are have moved their way through
the house
there's also legislation that's been
proposed by senator feinstein
congressman cicilline that addresses uh
some
banning an assault weapons ban which is
something the president worked to pass
in the 90s when he was
in the senate uh so there's a range of
steps that can be taken to increase gun
safety
i i agree with the people in the chat
who are saying that a lot of these
questions are sort of
just repetitive and and um
they don't give us any information like
the point here is they'd like to use
legislation to deal with guns and biden
might look at executive actions now the
question of
would it would biden be open to
proposing it himself and then giving it
to congress to try to pass
it it's really the same question biden
and democrats are going to work together
it's got to be passed in in the house
it's sort of like what what kind of an
answer do you expect you're going to get
at a certain point
to read out for you um you know he he is
somebody who obviously has a deep
connection to loss
um and uh we don't always read out those
calls i can check and see if there's
anything uh that has
uh that he has done that he'd be uh
comfortable conveying to all of you
sure could you give us an update on
progress from the family reunification
task force have there been
families children reunited back with
their parents where does that stand
right there there have been
uh and a lot of that has happened
through lawyers and outside groups and
the nga
ngo community that plays an incredible
role here there will be an update
provided at day 120
that will be more of an official report
and update out of the department of
homeland security
so in advance of that i'm not sure we'll
have incremental updates but there have
been
some progress made thanks in large part
to the work of uh
legal experts and ngos on the outside
they're in touch with them as well but
we'll have our first formal update on
day 120 and then i believe
every 60 days thereafter go ahead jeff
why did the president wait until there
was another shooting
until he addressed gun violence in
america uh he actually addressed it we
put out a statement in his name
on the anniversary of um in early
february the anniversary of the
of the shooting uh in florida um so he
has addressed it before and
i certainly have stressed it even as
president and will continue to address
it
as president and as you know jeff from
coming covering him in congress for a
long time
this has been a passion of his uh
putting in in place gun safety measures
throughout his career
that's why he fought to uh get the
birdie bill passed why he fought to
uh ban assault weapons why he was the
lead in the obama biden administration
and putting in place more than a dozen
executive actions
to to make it safer for our communities
and it's something he will continue to
work on as president of course he knows
though that the president's bully pulpit
is unparalleled and yet it took him
until more than 60 days into his
presidency to
talk about gun violence on camera in
america
what does that say about his commitment
or how much political capital he's
willing to spend on this issue
i have no problem with these questions
anybody who has been following
the tragedies and the shootings that
have happened in our country over the
past
several years if not decades knows that
this is an issue the president
is deeply committed to and his career
his uh like i accept that they're just
tests of rhetoric but i don't have a
problem with the question
spoken they're looking at what his uh
background has been
where he has fought the fights and he
has fought the fights on the brady bill
on the assault weapons ban on getting
legislation passed it wasn't successful
as was
alluded to earlier in a question we know
that
but this is something he's going to put
his shoulder into he's going to work
with members of both parties he's going
to
certainly advocate for and i think for
for those who have survived
gun violence for those who've lost
family members they're really looking
for right it's not particularly
substantive
i agree but it's not like i i think that
she could diffuse them the access being
granted
today for the pool is of a facility that
is aspirational
where you want to move these children
what about access to the facilities
where
there is overcrowding and there is an
actual uh
problem why was this one chosen over
them we're also open to providing access
there um and
this is just the first step in a process
of providing greater access to the media
and when would that decision be made
you've said earlier this week that
you would be working on access is this
the only access or
will that be coming you know i would i
would consider it
it's ongoing and we wanted to provide um
pool coverage as you all know who are in
the television uh
field of television that allows for
video a video camera to provide access
to all the networks
we felt that would be a good first step
and we're looking forward to
continuing to engage about how to
provide increased access you agree
though that you've chosen
the facility that is uh is the
aspirational facility
as opposed to the problem at this moment
well
i would say we all agree that the the
border patrol facilities are not places
where children should be
they are uh children should be moving
more quickly
through those facilities that is what
our policy central focus is
right now is obviously they're not going
to choose the worst
facility to show you of course health
concern
uh because of the number of kids who are
moving through those facilities and the
fact that
why not we we will and we are working
with the border patrol and
with dhs to to determine how we can do
that
go ahead jennifer um on iraq and
withdraw withdrawing us trips from
iraq to please give us an update on
iraq's request for the start of talks on
that withdrawal please
that's something we are looking forward
to convening next month
and i'm not sure if i have an update
other than to convey that we look
forward to our strategic dialogue with
the government of iraq
over the month of april the meetings
will further clarify
that coalition forces are in iraq at the
invitation of the iraqi government
and solely for the purpose of training
and advising iraqi forces to ensure
that isis cannot reconstitute and we are
committed first and foremost
to iraq's sovereignty we look forward to
these important discussions with iraqi
leaders on the future
of our partnership that will convene uh
next month
go ahead get a couple of quick ones for
you so on nordstrom 2
that is an issue that keeps coming up in
the relationship with germany
how soon do you think those sanctions
will be implemented
and has the president um had a chance to
discuss this
issue at his level with the chancellor
of germany
i don't have any uh calls although we do
read out the calls that he does so you
would certainly know if he had a call
with the chancellor of germany i can
assure you um
so not a new one uh that i'm aware of
that you are not aware of
um we continue to believe it's a bad
deal i don't think we have an update on
the
our policy position beyond that okay and
then um 14
states have now sued the administration
over the oil and gas of the cause and
oil and gas leasing
what do you say to that and how do you
move beyond that i mean how do you how
do you
you know i realize there's a legal
process but how do you address how do
you get your point across
in this legal environment well i would
say first
oil and gas jobs aren't going anywhere
the outgoing
administration flooded the oil markets
with cheap federal leases this will
not affect oil and gas production or
jobs for years to come
and what president biden has pledged to
do is invest to create jobs and ensure
america leads the clean energy
revolution which is where the industry
is largely going anyway where there is
the greatest
opportunity for job creation uh he wants
to create
good paying union jobs and uh that's
something he believes and he's committed
to doing i think there's a lot of
um there is some misinformation out
there about what this means which is why
it's not
i'm not saying from the media i'm just
saying in general um and
again there are oil and gas jobs that
are out there the existing leases will
continue he's really talking about
future releases
and just one more um on the gun issue i
know this is kind of a crazy question
but
it's always a good lead in when it's a
crazy question
this question will be insane people
trying to enact gun control legislation
in this country
is there some consideration to taking a
look at the second amendment
and oh boy addressing it from a
sort of the underlying constitutional
that's a minefield is that something
that the president
careful now jen called into question so
many years after
the revolution no one is talking about
overturning or changing the second
amendment
what our focus is on is putting in place
common sense
measures that will make our community
safer make families safer
make kids safer the majority of the
american public supports background
checks
the majority of the american public does
not believe that anyone needs to have an
assault weapon
so that's really what our focus is on at
this point in time
joe manchin is not in support of this
once
again you have a democrat a member of
the president's own party
who is already signaling that he will
not support that
you have a very slim majority can you
convince
republicans to support this legislation
that you can
work around you can't democrat that's
not supporting it
as the president said yesterday we don't
know yet he hasn't done the vote count
but it is certainly an issue he will
talk to members about and
convey why he feels it's so important
that it's not a
shouldn't be a political issue that
keeping our community safe family safe
looking at the track record as what has
worked in states which is very
informative and actually to josh's
earlier question
something that we know more about now
than we may have ten years ago
um so he will he will be uh conveying
that to to members he's
he's communicating with go ahead uh two
questions following up on we just
questions about representation
um the bad administration is the first
in 20 years to not have an
asian american lead one of the 15
executive departments in the cabinet so
how does the white house square that
back
with the president's pledges to make
this the most representative most
diverse
in history well i will just say the
president remains committed to making
sure this is the most diverse
administration in history that has
always been remains our goal we've made
a lot of progress
uh we have the most diverse cabinet in
history uh we but
we will continue to make progress we
have aapi staff at senior levels and at
all levels of the administration
and we will continue to work to find
ways to elevate aapi voices
at the highest level of government there
are a number of
cabinet level i know it's not 15 members
so but just to to note obviously
catherine tai who received a
overwhelming support in the senate in
her approval what about kamala
to be confirmed for ustr uh julie sue at
the department of
labor uh kieran i'm going to butcher
that name and i apologize to kiran
at opm todd kim the assistant attorney
general at doj
so we will continue and obviously there
are more positions and roles
that we need to fill and i will say
first and foremost the president's view
is that
we need to listen and that is an
important component of how we're
communicating
with members of congress as concerns
arise also with
leaders in the community as he and the
vice president did last friday
why it seems so important as we look to
policy making
to have senior members of our
administration do listening sessions in
the community to determine
how we can best address needs is it
there's personnel
of course and we will continue to work
toward that there's policies
and that's part of our objective and our
focus at this point in time and also a
quick one on guns um
the president also talked several times
about a federal assault weapons ban
and i'm wondering how he plans to build
a coalition around that when even when
that policy it's been asked four times
already democrats in congress well
though it is supporting that was the
question about i mean
they're asking the same question over
and over again um and
uh he will it's something that he has
had long had
a view and a belief that no one needs
an assault weapon that is not something
that should be
a part of what um what people have
access to
in this country um and he will uh
continue to
um so it's like you're asking kind of
who will he talk to or who would he
try to build a coalition in congress to
build up the torch well part of it is
certainly communicating with the
advocates it's communicating with
outside groups with gun owners many of
whom will tell you that they don't
believe
they would support an assault weapons
ban communicating with leaders in states
where
laws have been put in place that have
been impactful and obviously having
conversations with members he's known
for
some time having them at the staff level
and determining
if we can find a path forward go ahead
thank you jen i'd like to ask you uh two
questions the first about marijuana and
the second about a bit of a historical
mystery
i'm hoping you could help us solve okay
there's a lot of setups for these
questions
today i like it go ahead sure so uh
vice president kamala harris says that
she is a past marijuana smoker
she said quote it gives people joy and
we need more joy in this world
she is with a clear majority of the us
population in supporting marijuana
legalization
according to polls two-thirds of people
do this i like about half of republicans
yet last week the daily beast reported
that there were dozens of white house
staffers
who are either disciplined or terminated
from their jobs
for past marijuana use you seem to
confirm
five terminations on twitter and my
question is
why would president biden allow this to
happen especially considering
the white house staff were led to
believe that pop use would not be
disqualifying
especially considering the vice
president is herself a former marijuana
user
well let me first say that um what we
tried to do as an
administration was work with the
security service who actually makes
these determinations about
um about suitability for serving
in government in the past and i served
in the obama biden administration the
rules were actually far more stringent
so that isn't about anyone's personal
point of view it's about working through
the process
i think if he kept the question shorter
and said isn't it a double standard that
kamala's vp despite past marijuana use
and others were fired if you keep the
question
simpler she's i think she's less able to
do this
her comment last week five individuals
who
are no longer employed at the white
house a number of them
there were other uh security uh issues
that were raised
that's fair and you know that's an
unfortunate conclusion of course but
but what we tried to do is uh enable
additional
uh members of the team who would have
not have been able to continue serving
in past administrations
to continue serving by updating our
policy in coordination with the security
service follow up on that uh
surely president biden could you know
implement changes here
unilaterally and just say that these
people can come to work for him
well i think if marijuana was federally
legal that might be a different
circumstance
but i don't i don't think i have any
more for this on you on this for you go
ahead
more data on the number of people
impacted other than the five people who
were terminated
i don't have any more data for you other
than to convey that there are a number
of people who would not have been able
to serve in past administrations and
because of our efforts to modernize
uh and work with the security service
they're able to serve did you have
another question
okay um so this is a uh as i
set it up a bit of a mystery and i'm
sure that you've inquired about this
yourself and oh god okay
where's the cat no no it's not okay
so there was a report last year from the
senate finance and homeland security
committees it claimed that the wife of
moscow's former mayor
paid a company associated with the
president's son 3.5 million dollars
there was no explanation for this
alleged payments and i'm wondering if
you could tell us if
that claim is accurate and if so what's
the 3.5 how would she know about
hunter's business
familiar with that claim doesn't sound
like it's backed up by a lot of evidence
if you have evidence or specifics happy
to discuss it further committee's report
so you haven't asked about this or i i'm
not familiar with the report at all
um go ahead thank you with the may 1st
deadline
looming when do you expect to hear from
the president about the timing on
withdrawal from afghanistan uh it's a
good question as you may know uh
secretary blinken is currently in
brussels and talking
with our nato european partners he did
a press avail i believe it was yesterday
but let me reiterate a couple of the
points he made and then i'll get to your
question
uh that our focus right now is is for
him to
share some of our thinking with our
vital nato partners consult with them
hear from them on
where they see things going where they
want things to go
that as the president had said last week
it's tough meeting that may 1st timeline
and
the secretary of state reiterated that
in his remarks as well whatever we do
will be informed by
our allies and partners uh but uh the
president is currently
uh discussing of course with policy team
members on
on uh what is possible and uh i
hopefully will have an update soon but i
don't have a timeline on that for you
announcement this week
i can't give you a timeline it's really
up to his own decision making and when
he's prepared to talk about that
publicly
go ahead thank you jen um i have a
couple of foreign policy questions
i understand the administration has
already supported kovacs
is working with the ramp up production
kovacs
details of mexico and canada but where
is the president's position
on the request by more than 55 countries
as well as some democratic lawmakers on
uh making vaccine patent through the wh
or giving a waiver to that
well the the top priority uh of the
presidents
uh and of the united states is saving
lives and ending the pandemic in the
united states and of course
around the world that includes investing
in kovacs working with partners as we
announced with the quad
to produce a billion i love that the
subtitle spells kovacs the way that
the character takeshi kovacs from um
uh altered carbon it's like it's just a
it's instead of c-o-v-a-x it's so funny
i don't know why
to save lives so that's how we're
looking at it through the prism
there are probably there are a number of
steps a number of ways we are engaged in
addressing the global pandemic through
the global international community
and we'll look at a range of options but
i don't have any update for you on the
patent question
as a general principle do you believe
that protecting american innovation
and intellectual property of
pharmaceutical companies
outweighing the benefit of moving faster
towards equivalent free world sure i
absolutely understand your question what
i'm conveying is we look at every option
uh through the prism of whether it will
save lives and how many lives it will
save and
try to put our resources and efforts
into those that we think will be
most effective um you know obviously
part of that
is through engaging with the who i
mentioned
our quad partnership our meaningful
contribution to kovacs and
of course when we can we will share
vaccines as we have already
as we're already doing with canada and
mexico but we're looking at a range of
options
right now our focus is on continuing to
address
the pandemic that is ongoing in the
united states given a thousand people
are still dying every single day
another part of politics so
can you comment on media reports on
whether the administration is
considering joining
a group of south american nations to
push back against chinese illegal
fishing
how big of a problem does the
administration see
this kind of chinese practice of distant
water fishing
and would this be something that you
would consider with other other regions
including southeast asia and africa
sure it is a challenge and a problem and
one that we're watching closely and
for others who have not been following
this issue is closely it is an issue of
overfishing uh
in certain parts of the world it is
something our national security team is
certainly watching and following closely
um
i can see if there's more specifics on
their engagement to update you on
one domestic question go ahead the
question on a
vaccination for federal government
employees i mean so far
it's been pretty much where they live
right i mean if you're in dc you follow
dc rules maryland and so forth
is there any other kind of consideration
from from the white house to
just expand access to vaccines for
federal
government employees it's a great
question i'll have to check with our
covid team
obviously everyone will be eligible in
just over a month
including our government employees and
dc and virginia have already made that
commitment maybe maryland too i don't
want to leave them out
so that is good news for every federal
government employee but i can check and
see if there's more specifics
across the administration about our
approach go ahead in the background
um a couple of questions first i wanted
to ask about voting rights the senate
right now
is debating its own version of the for
the people act
um it's there are a few hang-ups with it
in the chamber i was curious how much
emphasis the president plans to put on
this um if he will be reaching out
directly
or if there's a team from the white
house that's working on this issue yes i
would say we're very engaged um closely
engaged
on s1 that is
being negotiated as you said and there
are changes being made which we fully
expected
that there would be as a number of
senators i believe have alluded to that
being a possibility and things they'd
like to see changed
so it's working its way through the
process we get regular updates
our legislative team does and we remain
very closely engaged
and i wanted to ask um leader mcconnell
has said that he hasn't been invited to
the white house and he hasn't had a
direct conversation since the
inauguration
oh i think he corrected that statement
i was curious um because i know
previously um
leader mccarthy had said that he had
tried to reach out to the white house to
get an invitation here
um does does the president plan to have
some sort of big you know meeting with
leaders from across the aisle
where we would see photos of them
together and things like that
i'm sure he would obviously have been
limited on kovid photos
in the east wing and at this point we'd
be very much in the east
the easter egg roll preparations which
of course we will not be but obviously
more important
substantive vital meetings than that
he's had a number of meetings bipartisan
meetings in the oval office he will
continue to do those
those have often been constructed with
committee chairs or
or um or members with specific
jurisdiction
uh he has he has a long friendship with
uh
with leader mcconnell he has spoken with
him uh he speaks with him regularly
we're obviously not going to read out
all of those calls and i expect that
we'll continue
i wanted to ask we've been seeing a lot
of images of spring breakers
especially in florida and i was curious
um
how aware of that the president if he's
being
updated on that regularly um and if he
plans to make any sort of
address or public appeal to people on
the issue
well we we do watch that closely the
president is briefed regularly by his
covet team
and of course he has seen the news
coverage thanks to all of you of
spring breakers uh who have been
gathering in far too many numbers uh
there of course were steps uh taken
locally
um in in in response uh to this we also
watched that
closely um you know i'm not sure i don't
have anything to
to preview for you in terms of him
addressing spring breakers publicly
i will say that his message broadly
speaking is that we are still
no ice luge joe biden will come out very
strongly against
the lives of the american people we need
to be vigilant we need to wear masks
we need to hand wash and that is a
message of course directly to anybody
who is
not abiding by the recommendations of
public health officials just one more
um do you have any update on the
president's plans will he be traveling
to boulder
i don't have any updates on that as you
all know this tragedy
only happened just about 36 hours ago
and
obviously that would be done in
consultation with local officials
who i'm who i know are still digesting
the events
and uh in their community working on
healing in their community
i can note since you reminded me he did
speak with the mayor this morning as
well
and he had spoken with the governor
yesterday and will remain in close touch
uh
let me just go to the back and then
we'll come back go ahead in the back
level thank you um
last week secretary blinken and nsa jake
sullivan had a meeting in anchorage the
chinese counterparts
have they have they given a briefing to
the president
on the china policy had it had does that
has it changed any chinese policy or the
vatican administration
although i know that the president has
spoken with secretary blinken and
national security adviser jake sullivan
since their return i don't have any
uh obviously they talk about a range of
national security issues ongoing policy
processes that are ongoing
we're currently taking stock of where we
are which includes close consultation
with allies and partners as i noted
secretary of state is in
uh brussels currently uh on the way
forward and we'll continue to work with
china
going forward uh when it's in the
interest of the american people so
we're in consulting internally
consulting with our partners and allies
and that's really the stage we're in at
this time
i have a question related to legal
immigration
when vice president by the senator she
supported the cause of
ead employment authorization cards for
h4 and
l2 visa holders now these guys are
saying most of them are women basically
they're saying there is very long delay
in issuing ead cards for h4 and l2 visa
holders
some of them have also went to the court
what is your
why these delayed that i think part of
the reason
we want to push for action on
immigration on the hill
is to move forward with expediting the
processing and
and doing that on several levels
including a number of the visas that you
just uh just introduced or just conveyed
so that's part of the reason why we
think that's such an important piece to
move forward
a final one a number of indian american
doctors whose job is to treat patients
during this government
government era they are on the hill
protesting against
and demanding elimination of country
quota for green guards
uh i know the white house has sent a
legislation to the hill
and that talks about that but they're
still protesting against
uh and faster implementation of that
passage of the bill uh what is present
message to those doctors
i think the president uh would would
reiterate that he believes that uh there
should be faster processing that
our immigration system is broken uh at
many levels and
uh of of the system and that he is eager
to for congress to move forward with
action there okay two in the back go
ahead
thanks john i'm back on guns um you
mentioned bipartisan meetings um i'm
wondering if you get
a little bit more of a sense of the
president's engagement
with congress on gun legislation this is
the sixth
essentially the same question has he
spoken to senator manchin at all about
his they already asked about mansion
i don't have any meetings to predict
obviously
you know this is an issue that is there
are a number of passionate
gun safety advocates on the hill as you
well know uh
would it be rude for her to say as i
already answered
three times on the first part and once
on mansion
like uh as it relates to the tragedy of
tuesday night he was of course in ohio
all day yesterday with a very full
schedule so i don't
he didn't have any calls yesterday but
um you know it's something he will
continue to look for ways to engage to
discuss
to advocate for action moving forward is
there an update on his joint session
to congress no update yet um we have
a speech coming up next week um and we
certainly he remains interested in and
committed to doing a joint session we
remain engaged with them but i don't
have an update on the specific timing
and if i can just ask one more from one
of the reporters in the pool who can go
here um there was an axios report today
that he met with historians to discuss
how aggressive he could be um on his
economic agenda among other topics
that's a good report confirm the meeting
and maybe tell us who was involved and
why he felt the need to meet with
historians on this
i will tell you presidents love
historians i know those from this is my
second president working for um
and you know i think it's important to
learn from
what worked and didn't work in the past
and
gain perspective from people who study
that so
he did meet with historians a couple of
weeks ago i don't have the list of names
in front of me i can see if there's more
details we can provide and
really it's meant to have an open
conversation about the challenges where
country our country is facing and
looking back at history and it's a
moment to step back and
and reflect and use it as lessons moving
forward
go ahead thanks jen um a few months
spending one on taxes as well i know you
can't
get into specifics at this point but
what the president is being briefed on
uh by his economic team in the upcoming
days is this an infrastructure package
is it the president's
buildback better plan combination of
both
give us an overview of what it's what it
is
well our buildback better agenda his
buildback better agenda
includes a number of components uh that
he talked about on the campaign trail
element infrastructure's part of it
making the tax code fair and one that
rewards work
and not wealth is part of it doing
better by our caregivers is part of that
increasing access to health care is part
of it
investing in our clean energy economy is
part of it there are several components
he talked about
on the campaign trail and right now what
he's talking with his economic team and
advisors about
are is uh what the scale the scope and
the components will look like
uh in what he's going to move forward
and propose next week
the three trillion dollar number has
been put out there um i know the white
house hasn't
confirmed that but it is is it possible
that it goes above three trillion
dollars like it's three trillion viewed
as
the cap or it's certainly possible it
could go even higher well
again i think what we're looking at is
all of those components as i just laid
out
all of which may not will not be in a
speech next week right this is
a big big components of his agenda that
he talked about on the campaign trail
so uh and right now he's having a
conversation about
the scale and the scope of what
proposals uh look like there's lots of
ways to you can't say
frame it to shape it size it um so i
don't have any more
to predict for you last one on this uh
before taxes um
speaking of size and scope it's possible
if it gets broken up that infrastructure
could be won so what is the president
what does the white house view as
infrastructure what falls under that
umbrella under infrastructure
there's a lot of ways to look at
infrastructure i can't preview for you
i'm not exactly asking this what will be
in the package that he's still
discussing but
obviously roads rails and bridges are
part of
what everybody historically thinks about
uh but there's also
um components like our cyber
infrastructure there's lots of ways to
look at infrastructure but
uh how what what is in a package that
you just can't
say in the coming months i i don't have
anything more to detail for you
and then on taxes the white house says
now that
families who make up to four hundred
thousand dollars
won't pay a penny more under the
president's uh potential plan
um to the federal government in taxes
so which is 98 of families so what about
individuals
if you're an individual and you make up
to blank
you won't pay more to uncle sam what
what is that 400 000
so the individual number is going to be
the same as the joint fight that doesn't
make sense
no more nobody no individual making uh
less than
100 400 000 will pay more in taxes that
doesn't make sense
and you make three hundred thousand
dollars let's just say
that's less than 400 right you're a
married couple
that makes three it's either household
or individual 450 the
300 isn't gonna traditionally taxes
the joint filers pay about it's double
but you're saying now it'll be the same
i think we'll have more to say when we
actually
that makes no sense done yet so this is
a commitment he made on the campaign
trail which he's committed to abiding by
but
uh once we propose a tax proposal we'll
have more to discuss on it so just to be
clear individual filers if you make up
to 400 thousand dollars you're an
individual you will not pay a penny more
just like families won't pay up anymore
that's right
i don't see how that's mathematically
possible can't be here today
yeah can you give us an update on major
and champ and whether oh
yeah i was waiting for this to come up
uh
of course um champ and major are here at
the white house
uh they joined the first family at camp
david last weekend and returned with
them on sunday
dogs will come and go and it will not be
uncommon for them to head back to
delaware on occasion
as the president first lady often do as
well
is it about the dogs
i'm colin kahl he's one of the
presidents yeah
he barely just made it out of con
committee right now can you say
is the white house still behind his
nomination it's been controversial from
the beginning any thoughts on that
absolutely uh colin is qualified he's
experienced
and he would bring an incredible
reservoir
of perspective uh to the job at the
department of defense
and so we look forward to his
confirmation so no consideration
whatsoever
of withdrawing his elevation
mcconnell question you said they speak
regularly he says that they've only
spoken one time he corrected his
statement saying this but one time on
burma
have they spoken beyond that one time i
don't have any more calls i don't think
to read out for you
and which we we will not make a case of
doing as you know
uh so i don't have more to read out for
you definition of bipartisanship
change since he arrived in office on
january 20th
no his his definition of bipartisanship
has always been
working on behalf of the american people
and governing for all people whether
it's democrats republicans independents
and
moving forward on proposals and policies
that will make their lives better
with or without republican votes well he
doesn't believe that bipartisanship is
defined by uh the zip code here he
believes it's on
how we can deliver relief to the
american people okay thanks everyone
do you have any timing when you might
announce a replacement for near and
tander
i do not i do not but shalonda young is
confirmed she will be the acting
um and so but i don't have a personnel
preview for you
on that particular role jen can i have
one more question on
china vaccine diplomacy is the
administration doing anything specific
to push back against requirements by
china for countries to cut back or
reduce ties to taiwan
i will check with our national security
team if there's anything for that on you
on that for you thank you
all right so white house press secretary
jen saki remember that tomorrow
it's joe biden in front of the media we
will have it live
i believe it's at 2 eastern it might be
at 1 eastern tomorrow but i hope that
you're going to
join me it doesn't make sense that
the income limit for paying taxes would
be four hundred thousand household and
four hundred thousand
individual with everything it there's
it's different
with the coveted relief cash it's up to
75k as an individual or 150
for a couple um it it doesn't make any
sense so
she she's wrong about that i'm not
saying she's lying
she just is wrong and hopefully we'll
get a clarification on that
also later today at 3 p.m eastern we'll
be recording
some live calls so if you want to
participate in that
do it via discord davidpakman.com
discord so i'll see everybody who wants
to call in then and otherwise tomorrow
for biden's press briefing